I get a lot of questions about
programming but I don't think they're
the right questions to ask questions
like how many languages do I need to
learn what language do I need to learn
to get to company X what's the
difference between a and B and which
makes more money what are the exact
steps I need to take to become Z what
kind of program should I write to build
up my resume so why don't I like these
questions because it feels like the
people who are asking these questions
they are learning how to program just
for the sake of learning how to program
but programming is just a tool being a
programmer for me means you write code
to automate things or to make things
perform certain actions for example
programming a refrigerator to turn on
the light when you open the door when
you think about it programming is
actually kind of boring you're just
giving a series of instructions to a
machine over and over again until you
get it right I don't want to speak for
all of you but I think if the pay wasn't
great I don't think a lot of you would
spend hours and hours every night in
front of your computer trying to learn
how to code or to just debug your
program sometimes we get caught up
learning languages or doing coding
challenges or fantasizing about you know
working for these big tech companies
that we forget why we wanted to learn
programming in the first place you
wanted to program because you saw the
amazing things that can be built using
programming so don't just learn how to
program build something that matters
build something that means
build something that solves a problem
you're a problem-solver a creator an
innovator you're not a programmer
programming is just a tool in your
arsenal to build something amazing you
can be analytical creative empathetic
and programming allows you to express
those qualities of yourself but
programming in of itself is nothing
special it's like a pencil it can mark
stuff down if you press on the pen so
hard enough that's it but with a pencil
you can write novels draw beautiful
portraits build plans for a skyscraper
or anything eliminated only by your
imagination
you don't learn how to program to get
into Google you learn how to program to
build something meaningful something
that helps real people with real
problems
I'm partnered with IBM today to talk
about a global initiative called call
for code which calls for developers to
build something impactful and have a
positive change across the world through
their code as you know there are
hundreds and hundreds of natural
disasters every year like hurricanes
earthquakes floods volcanoes and
wildfires those affect numerous lives
and causes tremendous damage to many
families around the world if you strive
for real impact we desperately need you
this is why 2018 call for code global
challenge is a competition that asks
people like you to build solutions to
improve what we can do to reduce
disruptive impact of these natural
disasters we need all kinds of
technologies you like working on
blockchains build secure supply networks
to help distribute aid to the people in
need you're like AI are NLP make BOTS to
help real-time communications to them
you're into data science analyze and
predict what the affected population
needs before they even ask for it every
one of your project will matter and it
will be for an extremely good cause now
of course it is still a competition so
they have a grand prize of $200,000 not
only that the project the greatest
potential impact will be implemented
with the help of IBM the new Linux
Foundation the UN Human Rights and the
American Red Cross
sorry offers challenge so don't forget
don't be a programmer be a problem
solver
going to call for code